You can now give Claude infinite memory and reduce your token usage by 71.5 times by installing
this one skill, these are the three easy steps.
By the way, this is based on Andre Corpathy's system with the inventor of vibe coding.
So he kind of knows what he's talking about, you know?
The first step is to go to Disgiatry Repo scroll down, copy this inside of your Claude code.
Once installed, run the graphified skill inside of your main Claude folder so it will map
out every single file inside of that folder.
By the way, if you want to skip all of that and you want to copy just one command,
comment, graph and make sure to follow me.
Then go to obsidian.md, download it, open your main Claude folder as a fault, click
open Graph View and you will get something like this or like this.
The third step is to add this inside of your Claude.md file so every time we send a prompt,
it will look at the map that it built and use 75 times fewer tokens.
If you want the full step by step guide including the cool visual you can build, just comment,
graph and I'll send it to you, otherwise make sure to follow the scum for more videos like this.